foreign
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar go with the flow for Rapid
viscosity results with honey bun
I am Kaylee Bach of lab Roots an lbr
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by Unchained labs
to learn more about our sponsor please
visit unchainedlabs.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker
Kevin Lance PhD director of biologics
and gene therapy marketing at Unchained
Labs Kevin you may now begin your
presentation
Kevin I'm here to show you how you can
go with the flow with honey bun the most
rapid viscometer out there
in the world of antibodies and other
biologics the big trend is to move
towards high concentrations but those
higher concentrations come hand in hand
with the problem of high viscosity when
you're developing a drug for injection
viscosity is the biggest Factor telling
you if your sample will struggle with
syringe ability or injectability in the
worlds of antibody engineering and
formulation viscosity raises the alarm
when your antibody is prone to Sticky
self interactions or if your formulation
isn't going to cut it in process
development High viscosity can lead to
issues with filtration or fill finish
processes
but the problem is getting viscosity
data is too slow so no one is getting as
much viscosity data as they need old
school instruments use too much volume
and only run one sample at a time even
modern tech that just needs microliters
of sample has complicated workflows that
require hours of Hands-On time and add
to that with lots of upkeep from
clogging and cleaning
honey bun is the only rapid viscosity
system built to solve these problems
honeybun can take 10 samples at a time
and in just a few minutes get viscosity
data it does this using only 35
microliters for each sample and samples
up to 10 centipoids will run in less
than one minute and honey bun can run a
full range from 0.5 to 150 centipoids to
prep your sample only takes minutes
since all you have to do is pipette it
into the consumable and work through the
quickest software steps you've ever seen
how does honey bun do this well it all
starts with its consumable the bun
each bun can run from 1 to 10 samples
and any channels that aren't used can be
saved for later to prep for a run simply
add in 35 microliters of a sample into
an input well and that's it gone are the
days of filling syringes or cleaning
expensive chips that are prone to
clogging since these buns are disposable
the Bun's secret ingredient is the
microfluidic channel connecting the
input well and the output well the
microfluidic channel has two sections
the resistance Channel marked by an r
and the measurement Channel marked by
the m
inside of honey bun compressed gas
pressure pushes the sample through the
resistance Channel
the pressure applied we call that Delta
p
uh
notice how the resistance channel is
much smaller than the measurement
Channel that's what allows the channel
to have high resistance to flow in the
resistance section but then the larger
measurement Channel means that the flow
can be tracked over a few minutes by a
simple camera
in the measurement channel uh camera is
used to see the Leading Edge of fluid
and then velocity and flow rate Q can be
calculated viscosity is determined by
dividing the pressure applied by the
honey bun and the flow rate through the
microfluidic channel combined with the
length width and height geometry of the
resistance Channel
to load the bond into the honey bun all
it takes is a simple push the loading
mechanism works just like loading a
memory card into a computer or if you're
old enough holding a floppy disk into
also a computer
uh then the honeybun software is
designed to get you to viscosity answers
as fast as possible
from the honey bun home screen all
that's really needed is to name the
experiment and pick which channels where
you're running samples and that's it if
you want you can click Start or you can
name your experiment samples and adjust
temperature but to run the software you
only really need three clicks of the
mouse after you load up the sample and
hit start you'll get to watch as the
samples flow through the bond so you can
keep an eye on which samples are flowing
fastest
all the data is automatically exported
afterwards as an Excel file an HTML file
and an image showing how each Channel
ran and if you want you can save the
video too
here's exactly what a ROM looks like
inside of honeybun as it applies
pressure to push sample through the Buns
microfluidic channels this is shown in
real time
how fast samples move through each
channel is related to the viscosity here
we're looking at water a two centipoi
standard and a six centiploid standard
at positions one two and three and
that's repeated twice more on this bun
you can see in the overlays how the
software is tracking the Leading Edge of
the sample so it can later calculate
viscosity
here we're looking at a actual video of
running a sample on honey bun to show
that it really is that simple all you
have to do is tell the instrument where
you're running the sample pipette 35
microliters into the bun so here I'm
running a sample of glycerol and water
with a little bit of blue food coloring
so we can see it better on the camera
and then push the sound the button into
the honey bun and we're ready to go back
to the software and hit start you notice
as soon as that bun was loaded into
honey bun then the live video popped up
and the first thing that happens after a
after hit start is a short temperature
incubation to make sure that the bun and
your sample are correctly at the
temperature you set most viscosity
experiments are going to be run either
at 20 or 25 degrees Celsius but honey
bun can control sample temperature
between 10 and 45 degrees
after the incubation what we'll see here
on the left is that sample is going to
run through the resistance Channel and
then start being tracked by the software
just like we saw in the earlier video on
the last slide
so this whole run because it's on a
sample it is you know less than 10
centipoys uh takes about one minute and
that includes the 20 second incubation
that we saw when the sample reaches that
line of circles then it's completed its
run all the velocity data has been
tracked and the instrument is going to
calculate viscosity from that pressure
versus flow rate curve
all we do then is again pop the bun back
out of the instrument and we're done
that's a complete viscosity read done in
about a minute on a single sample but if
we wanted to run 10 samples at a time it
would take the same amount of time to
run that bun
thank you
okay when we do run 10 samples at a time
the results that we'll see look
something like this
so here we're looking at uh 10 different
IGG concentrations formulated in PBS
we're looking at averages with error
bars showing standard deviation
you can see as concentration increases
then viscosity also increases for our
IGG sample
and in this case our standard deviation
is actually coming from Honey Buns
ability to run multiple Shear rates in a
single run so each data point is really
the combination of many calculative
viscosities
so what that means is honey bun will
start the pressure low and increase the
pressure high to high during each run so
that sample starts slowly and runs
faster and we're going to take the
average and standard deviation to show
that average viscosity here
because honey bun is taking samples
through that pressure ramp that also
means that we get a lot of different
Shear rate data for each one of those
samples so at the same time that all
this viscosity data was gathered honey
bun also applies that low to high
pressure ramp on this these antibody
samples which means they run slower
which is lower Shear rates or faster
Which is higher Shear rates and we get
an understanding of this each and every
sample is showing Newtonian or
non-etonian behavior of the viscosity of
Newtonian samples will be flat across
different Shear rates which is what
we're seeing and non-Newtonian Shear
thinning or thickening samples will show
dramatic change at different Shear rates
when you run samples on a bun you know
that each bun is served up with
Precision so to show this off IGG from 0
to 75 milligram per milliliter it was
measured in triplicate but each
replicate is actually measured on a
different bun
Honey Buns Precision across all those
samples has a less than two percent
coefficient of variation which is great
and the specification for Honey Bun on
this kind of experiment would be around
three percent CV
if we want to compare that type of
experiment between honey bun and old
school cone and plate rheometers it's a
little bit more convenient to do it on
high concentration glycerol water
samples so that we see much higher
centipoids which is more ideal for
reading samples on a cone and plate
instrument
and you can see that here the results
agree within one to four percent between
honey bun and our cone and plate
instrument where they're both getting
the same viscosity results at 30 at the
controlled 30 degree Celsius temperature
but importantly if they agree uh you're
still going to want to run samples on
honey bun because with even with these
high concentration High viscosity
samples Honey Buns running those and
about 10 minutes total and get through
10 samples at a time in those 10 minutes
meanwhile the cone and plate experiment
because you're running one at a time
samples you're going to take about 120
Minutes to get through all 10 of those
samples if we ran these samples on a
microfluidic system where you know there
are other microfluidic viscosity systems
out there running those 10 samples takes
about 28 minutes
and because honey bun can run things at
any temperature you can get your
viscosity data at that range of
temperatures as well so here we're
showing a really quick and easy
experiment where we've taken a single
concentration of our favorite IGG sample
and run it at four different
temperatures to understand how viscosity
changes across temperature
but where honey bun really shines is the
ability to do both temperature control
and high throughput experiments at a
very precise uh you know with very
precise viscosity data so here we're
looking at temperature control between
10 and 25 degrees Celsius at five
different concentrations of IGG where
we're running samples in triplicate at
each one of these data points
so across all of these results we're
still seeing great Precision where we've
shown the highest concentration coldest
sample still shows a 0.8 percent CV
on any other device this would be a
massive undertaking but on honey bun
we're actually done in less than you
know less than a few hours where Honey
Buns results are exactly needed to
pinpoint the trend in viscosity versus
concentration for this antibody and
understanding the trend for temperature
for this antibody
want to take a look at another case
study uh honey bun we can have say this
therapeutic antibody where we want to
Target which concentration we want to
use for our injectable formulation
so if we go to really really high
concentrations in other words what's
going to be ideal for what we can
actually inject
well the first part of that problem is
understanding the concentration that our
antibody solution is at so for that
we're going to use our stunner
instrument which is going to confirm the
concentration in with a minimal volume
of sample
stunner is going to bring together
quantification by UV Vis with the
ability to gather size and poly
dispersity data from DLS those are great
because they're both label free fast
methods those reads are going to be done
on the same two microliter sample for up
to 96 samples at a time that makes
thunder ideal for determining antibody
concentration and to check it for any
aggregation at the same time on the same
sample
so here we see exactly what that looks
like I'm using water with the
fluorescein die just so you can
visualize it well on camera here you
load in two microliters a sample into
each one of our microfluidic wells on
stutter and that will Wick into the
sample and be prepared to be red inside
of each of those microfluidic circuits
coming out of that you'll get both UV
Vis information where we're going to
look at the absorbance Peak at 280
nanometers and you'll get DLS
information where we understand the
distribution of size sizes that are
antibody sample has
for this you know case study if we run
our sample and analyze it at a260 we're
confirming our concentrations between 36
and 150 milligram per milliliter we also
had a fourth sample but that did exceed
stunners 40 cent of poise viscosity
limit so we did extrapolate for that a
higher roughly 300 milligram per ml
sample and then by DLS also read at the
same time on stunner we're seeing PDI
values between about 0.15 and 0.25 which
indicates a little bit of aggregation is
going on but nothing you know nothing
crazy where we don't have massive
Aggregates present
we'll also note that the graph shown on
the right the correct size values does
actually need the viscosity data from
honey bun fed back into the system so
that we know the right size for things
based on the viscosity that they they
have in solution
so if we take four different antibody
concentrations and our buffer solution
as well and feed those through honey bun
the results we get look like this where
we have our buffer sample and then as
we're adding more and more antibodies
into solution we see viscosity goes
higher and higher all the way up to our
300 milligram per milliliter sample and
we're crossing our injectability
viscosity limit which is between 20 and
25 centipoids somewhere between our 150
and 300 milligram per ml concentration
so that gives us uh the ability to to
start focusing more on where between
those two antibody concentrations we
need to
to be to exactly stay to maximize our
concentration but stay under our
viscosity limit
and if we want to take advantage of
honey bun and look at the shear rate
data that's gathered at the same time
across those samples we can look at that
data and see that all of these samples
are behaving uh with Newtonian flow so
they're nice and flat across the shear
rates measured
so key part of all of that viscosity
workflow to understand concentration of
viscosity behavior is honey bun because
with honey bun you can finally get all
the viscosity data as you want as fast
as you want it and nothing will be
stopping you from getting your viscosity
groove on
with that I'd love to take any questions
you have for me
well thank you Kevin for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
is
are the Buns reusable
so each channel in a bun is one-time use
but you can use one channel on one day
and come back the next day to use the
so that means you never have to worry
about you know chips clogging or
cleaning up afterwards uh since you can
just use each of these channels one time
and move on
perfect great thank you
our next question here asks what is
shear rate good for
okay so it's it's helpful to understand
if you have a Newtonian or non-Newtonian
samples if you're trying to inject the
non-etonian sample for example uh the
viscosity could increase or decrease as
your injection force is applied so
basically you're trying to push this
sample faster it's going under higher
higher Shear rates how does viscosity
change sometimes it stays constant
sometimes it increases sometimes it
decreases so looking at a range of Shear
rates helps to characterize that
behavior
our next question asks how long does it
take for one CP or 150 CP samples
so at one Center Poise a honey bun read
is about a minute long you saw in the
video it takes about 40 45 seconds plus
a 20 minute or 20 second incubation time
and at 150 centipoise that's about 10
minutes total somewhere to the 8 to 10
minute range
great thank you
next question here you mentioned honey
bun runs based on compressed gas what
kind of lab gas supply is it need or is
needed
so honey bun works great with nitrogen
from a house Supply or from a tank since
it doesn't consume much volume so even a
tank will last a while it also works
great with compressed air and if using
compressed air that air just needs to be
in a certain quality spec that the gas
is uh you know dust free of dust water
and particles like a clean dry air type
of supply
right
next question here does the measurement
require a die in the sample
no uh nothing extra is needed to a
sample it's really quick to just pipette
your set your microliters out of a tube
and add it into the honey bun it's a lot
of videos I'll show something with like
a blue or green die and that's just
because the buns are transparent can be
hard to see what's going on without a
diet
great
but we're going to go ahead and wrap up
here Kevin I want to thank you again for
your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor Unchained labs for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
lab Roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care everyone goodbye